[Música]
vamos mostrar hoje aqui é um coelhinho o
papel que a arte tem na minha vida e
tenho no meu percurso até agora é espero
que consiga fazer quarta desta minha
caminhada é que vamos encontrar aqui um
bocadinho uma história tão linda tabela
terra
o clima aqui é como se tivesse nascido
aqui a maior parte das crianças da minha
idade na geral hoje em clima de ensino
em algumas aptidões na área artística
pra mim é perfeitamente normais
os blues a minha mãe começar a desenhar
e com 5 e 6 as coisas pra mim aquilo era
super banal e até que os meus pais
acharam que não era uma coisa normal eu
desenhar uma coisa tão perfeita tem pena
não ter igualado no primeiro design mas
pronto é então constroem assim uma
curiosidade jogo há tanto tem jeito a
desenhar então hora de tomar mas possui
sinais porque tudo era fácil de aumentar
a altura em que o passava bastante tempo
em casa doente era uma criança estava
muitas vezes doentinha ficava em casa e
aquilo que eu mais gostava de fazer era
a modelagem hoje ensina e desenhar
enquanto todas as outras crianças que
brincava e um era mais é mais né
nesta base depois quando entrar e é o
segundo com cinco
pretória o tipo mais sua impressora
chamada filomena que o gênero não teve
encontrar entre nós é chamar os meus
pais ascol eles que cria o vapor ligou
que eu tinha 11 anos
o pequenino agora por lisboa nem pensar
ela vai permanecer equilibrando algum
tempo ainda depois vamos ver mas porque
o personagem de outro jeito
ah eu acho que ela tem grande potencial
e nadal tinha equipamentos roupas
desenvolver o seu talento é normal o que
é certo é que os meus colegas não tinham
tanto já no design como eu pedi umas
coisas olha faz uma aqui sim é fácil e
que não existe mais isso e uso da água
nunca pensei só mais tarde que iria
fazer parte do meu caminho e que eu
faria isto mais a sério fazia designs
aparentemente simples
está aqui um deus já é muito antigo
depois quando entrei para a escola
secundária
os professores de educação visual novo
para realizar essa questão
na altura fazemos uns testes na
psicólogo para ver quais eram as áreas
com maior aptidão e pronto era sempre a
arte à parte embora daqui
mauá sp a coimbra porque nós não
tínhamos aqui o grupamento da arte
infelizmente continuamos a não ter e
tentaram fazer foi proporcionar o melhor
para conseguir fazer na altura a opção
então hipótese para então o brother e
optem por uma escola levou algum tempo
14 anos foi até coimbra e foi uma das
minhas costas onde aprendi imensa coisa
onde foram
mostrados diferentes materiais materiais
que eu desconhecia é materiais que se
aguentaram outro tipo sedan de
importação e do registro de pessoas
bastante creme que nesta escola
basicamente obrigavam a fazer uma
representação do real com toda minúcia e
minhas a hoje práticas eram aquelas que
mais agrava e que pra mim não era longe
era o máximo
e neste curso de artes muito dinheiro
foi muito bem gasto muito investimento e
depois quando acabou então e agora
agora é uma fase em que fui mais a minha
atenção em determinados pintores
trabalhar o assunto é base do realismo
nos a mãe depois acaba por parar na
escola nas caldas da rainha e é que é
que foi mais complicado nas caldas me
descobrir que a arte é uma infinidade de
coisas
ar não é apenas o que nós vemos é aquilo
que nós sentimos que ela pode
representar as várias formas narrativas
podemos pegar nestes fatos e oval a
qualidade da obra de arte colocar lento
museu
estamos a dar um novo contexto e passa a
ser uma obra barata
quando eu cheguei esta escola eu tive
que pagar tudo aquilo que eu tenha feito
até aqui e vamos mostrar nós quando
trabalhamos muitos anos kits
em cancún vamos lá ver vamos o café e eu
vamos o bloco e vamos fazendo registros
gráficos que as pessoas tomem café à
vista que o desenho fez em parte da da
minha vida da minha rotina
raramente passava um dia que não
desenhar se nós vamos atingindo um grau
de maturidade também diferente vamos
conseguir sempre evoluir em termos
técnicos
eu achava que isto já era uma boa
evolução e para além do que vivia nesta
terra e tem a frase do melhor pra mim
sempre foi assim sinto muito que o curso
e eu tenho aquela escola e eu éramos uns
melhor a realidade
obrigado mesmo realismo e os outros eram
mais ligados à parte é abstrata e os
professores começaram nós tínhamos que
apresentar
vamos imaginar dez trabalhos por aula
chegávamos manhã 9 da manhã os trabalhos
e cada vez que eu chegava quando cheguei
lá no início não não é nada disso que
nós queremos tudo desculpa ao apêndice
muito bem sim mas não é nada disso
nós queremos nós queremos todos constrói
sua realidade já que gostam de trabalhar
paisagem
acho que essa minha desconstruir não foi
fácil para mim nada mesmo que vá alturas
complicadas porque achava que não era
aquilo que eu queria
lisboa o que estou a fazer agora não
posso fazer aquilo que eu quero eu vou
ter que observar aquilo que o professor
quer
e foi assim cinco anos
é um méxico
hoje percebo que essa desconstrução é
vai rolar frutos não naquela altura mas
hoje nos dias de hoje ela vai ouvir na
frente já vou explicar porque a essa
desconstrução a um trabalho é feito uma
leitura de enfrenta uma forma de
trabalho é desde o uso do e traz desde o
uso de lanchas
é eu lembro que o cozinha trabalho já
usavam linha e goiânia
tanto o sul na altura era assim
queremos um trabalho diferente queremos
um deslizamento total e que o que foi
aprendido em termos realismo é
completamente abstrato que ficou assim
eu saí no meu quinto ano com trabalhos
deste gênero ou mais destes ou
experimente quem gosta vai estar
disponível no ar quem gosta mais dos
outros
ok o curso para figueiró ainda poderei
ficar para o ano já que o vídeo pra
preferir o que tenho vindo a fazer até
hoje é trabalhar né na área das artes
tem parada várias expressões artísticas
desde 2006 aos nossos cliente e opinião
realmente acho que nós devíamos ter uma
educação e falta muito isso no nosso
ensino porque eles não tivessem os pais
que tiveram a capacidade do edu ler a
leitura de pressão e desvalorização de
preocupação e não tinha e não tinha
aprendido que aprendi a fazer o que eu
acho que é isso que falta na nossa
escola no nosso ensino dos nossos
currículos não estão muito adaptados
agentes cidades reais das nossas
crianças e acho que os viam ter mais
horas deste tipo de rã mas negava a a
sorte em algum momento artístico pronto
e agora neste momento que vão perder
mais visibilidade porque comecei a fazer
mais umas coisas vão fazendo as vezes de
90 e que me pedem pra fazer tratos
às vezes pensava assim então os meus
colegas eram os colegas nas causas em
alguns deles não tinham mesmo jeito
nenhum
a única categoria que nós tínhamos era
desenho é um dos anos é permitido fazer
um trabalho mais realista eu lembro que
há alguns que eu ainda consegui até é
sempre um dinheirinho extra que entra e
quando valoriza o nosso trabalho é o
time vamos fazendo aquilo que gostamos
desde o intervalo agora é aula o óleo
acrílico técnica mista
para além disso ainda também ainda
trabalhar e costumo fazer agora não tem
tanto tempo que os filhos precisam da
atenção também gosta de ficar um
bocadinho artesanato está alguns
trabalhos que já fiz
também para a mente
e pronto temos isto que é a arte urbana
na área urbana é um projeto céu é essa
aqui de figueiró dos vinhos em parceria
com a câmara municipal na altura vieram
falar comigo para eu desenvolver este
projecto ficará responsável por eu vou
aceitar e achei que era um desafio
interessante e acho que falta mais
coisas destas desta envergadura desta
iniciativa acho que foi muito
interessante
tivemos uma temática ligada à pesca à
pesca de trutas e resolvemos fazer essa
mostra é na feira internacional fiz
traiu e 1ª feira é foi feita aqui no
país nessa temática é isto foi um
projeto inclusivo porque tivemos idosos
de várias instituições plantei aqui no
nosso concelho é e institucionalizado em
institucionalizados
tivemos a universidade sénior envolvida
da mãe vivemos a comunidade foi a
comunidade que fechou este rendinhas
todas para conseguir montar é estas
coisas e as pessoas não sabiam bem
tratamos a fazer umas rendas umas coisas
mas nós sabemos bem o que isto vai dar
o princípio foi pedido que fizessem
posteriormente foi depois que eu fiz um
esboço de caba da obra está no lago
[Música]
agradeço a o executivo porque foi
extremamente importantes na concessão
desta destas peças é que os rogério
bittar da câmara era um ajuda nas bases
e fui me queria lutar para conseguirmos
fazer isto no fundo não tivessem passado
meu caminho e não tinha pagado em
e foi de florais com eles e é nessa
perspectiva que é tudo importante mesmo
que não seja fácil às vezes fazendo
dessa ligação é uma ligação da nossa
identidade mas às vezes vai fazê lo para
conseguir desligar e ele pensa porque é
esquiar nos permitam pensar aquilo como
gaia e também foi feito aqui muita
reutilização do material coisas que
estavam na festa escolas por exemplo
aqui tô que tô magníficas da comunidade
foi foi mesmo espetacular toque nove
metros de comprimento e três de largura
não foi fácil muito a linha a nossa
truta nossas primeiras os lápis e não tô
aqui todas a biblioteca é ver um papel
extremamente importante também a
funcionárias foram colegas as minhas
coisas foram muito estáveis e ajudaram
tiveram e também idéia de fazer algumas
destas peças que estão expostas na
biblioteca
[Música]
o que vocês ganham de carro
obrigado e arte esteja sempre conosco
porque é o alimento da nossa alma